this is cereth registered nurse Orion
doc home and in this video I want to
demonstrate how to remove surgical
staples so before you do this procedure
of course you have to verify the
physician's order because you will get
an order to remove the surgical staples
and pay attention to what that order
says because some physicians just want
you to remove every other staple while
some physicians want you to remove all
of them and if you do remove just every
other staple the patient whenever
they're discharged and have their first
post-op visit they will have rest of the
staples removed the next you'll want to
talk to the patient explain to them what
you're going to be doing and get their
consent to remove the surgical staples
and let them know that this procedure
typically is painless they may feel like
tugging or pulling at the surgical site
you can offer them pain medication if
it's ordered because you know this is a
wound that can be tender and then you're
going to gather your supplies now always
check with your Hospital protocols on
how they want you to remove surgical
staples because some hospitals require
that you wear sterile gloves when you do
this others say you can wear clean
gloves so follow that here we're going
to be doing it with sterile gloves so
it's best to get a dressing change tray
which includes a lot of the stuff you
need and include your sterile gloves
your drape for your supplies you're in a
septic to clean the surgical site before
and after and extra gauze and things
like that another thing you'll need is
steri-strips and why series strips
well one complication that can happen
whenever you're removing surgical
staples or even sutures is that the
wound can open up called wound
dehiscence and if that does happen when
you do remove a staple or a suture you
want to stop cover it up with a sterile
dressing and notify the physician
immediately but the steri-strips will
help prevent that and just maintain
wound integrity and we'll be applying
those after we've removed the staples
and of course you will need a skin
staple remover kit and in this kit will
come with the staple remover also has
alcohol prep and Gaulle's and then when
you're ready to start removing the state
what you want to do first of course is
perform hand hygiene and if the patient
has a dressing over the surgical site
where you're going to be removing the
staples you can dawn clean gloves remove
that old dressing then perform hand
hygiene again and get ready to open up
your sterile kit to remove the staples
now after you do that you want to take a
good look at the wound look at it does
it look infected is it extremely red
like this which can indicate that
there's infection if so you need to let
the physician know or does the wound
look like it's not really ready for the
staples to come out you can just take a
look at it and notice if you remove that
staple that wound may open up again let
the position know and an important thing
to remember is that staples can be in
all variety of directions like friends
and look at these pictures here you can
have them up and down the abdomen you
can have them in a sense crossing they
can be in all different directions so
always be aware of that as well so first
what we're gonna do is we're going to
get everything prepared and prepped so
we're going to open up our sterile
dressing tray you got to be real careful
not to break sterile field with this so
we're gonna open it up and on the top we
have our gloves which we can take out
hit right here we have our drape which
we're going to carefully grab and lay
right here because we're going to spread
that out and you also have your alcohol
prep and some other supplies so what
we're going to do now is open up our
drape so we're just going to gently open
it and we have about two inches on the
inside to be able to reach so we can
open it up then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna open up our supplies over
here in the packages and gently drop it
on to the sterile field because we'll
need to be using those and we want them
to stay sterile as well so we're going
to open our skin stapler and remover and
just gently drop it into the field
discard that we're gonna open up our
steri-strips as well and then discard
that now we're going to Don our sterile
gloves
and once we have these long we want to
be careful just to really touch the
things that are in our sterile field
because if we touch something on the
outside it will contaminate our gloves
if you're not familiar with how to put
on sterile gloves please check out my
other video on how to do that so we're
gonna open those up and we're just gonna
pull the tabs because we don't want to
touch the gloves we can touch the inside
of the gloves the cup for not the
outside I'm going to glove my right hand
first I'm gonna grab this part of the
cuff and just slide it over a little bit
then I want to take this other hand
slide it underneath the other glove and
glove my left hand and a lot of times
you have to rearrange these because the
manufacturer sometimes put those in
there and wear it cause you have trouble
to get them on so and then we're ready
now we're going to open up our
antiseptic because we're going to clean
the surgical side before and then after
we remove the staple before we place the
steri-strip so we're gonna open up our
alcohol prep sticks and you have three
of those in there so we're going to take
one of those and clean that area so
we're going to take the swab and we're
going to clean along the incision line
on both sides this is going to help
decrease infection now we're going to
discard the swab and we're going to let
this dry once the area is dry we're
ready to remove our staples now our
order said to remove all the staples and
to do that what we're going to do is
we're first going to remove every other
staples starting with the second staple
and while we're doing this is because we
don't want this incision to open up
prematurely so that helps hopefully
decrease that chance of happening and if
it does start to happen again
what you want to do is you want to cover
it up with a sterile covering and notify
the physician so what we're gonna do is
we're going to get our gauze and we're
going to take it just lay it right there
so we can easily drop each staple onto
the gauze as we're removing it why are
we doing this well these staples are
small they can fall into a patient's bed
on the floor and they're sharp and they
can poke someone so keeping them on the
goal this helps them stay collected and
after you move each staple you want to
count how many staples you've removed
total and document that so take the
staple remover and we're going to start
at the second staple and what you're
going to do if you can notice here the
mouth of the staple remover we're gonna
take this little part that's curved and
placed that underneath the staple just
like this and then we're going to
depress the handle we're not going to
pull up on the staple remover to help
assist the staple to come out because
this device will do it for you so we're
just going to gently depress and see
comes right out then we're gonna take
our staple and drop it into our gauze
now we're gonna repeat again go under
the other staple depress pulls it out
for you put in the gauze and then do the
same thing with this we're gonna get a
new swab and we're going to just clean
those areas where we remove the staple
and again just decreasing infection and
we're gonna let this dry and we're going
to apply steri-strips
so we're gonna discard this swab so the
area's dried and we have our
steri-strips and we're going to apply a
series strip to each area where we
remove the staple now we have cutter
steri-strips so that each side of the
strip will extend about 3/4 of an inch
from the incision they always follow
your hospital protocols or whatever the
surgeon instructs you to do with the
length of the steri-strip now the thing
you want to remember about series strips
is whenever you're applying them you're
gently just going to lay them on the
incision you're not going to create
tension or pull then or anything like
that because these serious strips are
strong and they could actually share the
skin or tear the skin so as I do that
you will see I'm not pulling or tugging
on the strip to create tension and
addition we want to keep about a
one-eighth inch space in between our
strips so with each package of
steri-strips there tore bite there which
helps you be able to access the strip
easier so we're gonna take off our first
strip and we're going to make sure we're
lining it up where it has about 3/4 of
an inch on each side and we're going to
first lay it down on one side and gently
just smooth it down and then not putting
tension or anything like that lay it on
the other side and smooth it down then
we're going to get another strip and
just repeat the same way okay again just
long enough where we make sure we have
enough on each side
then we're going to place our last one
on this round and then we'll remove the
other staples again just lining
everything up
now we're going to remove the other
staples just like how we did the other
ones before so again just take the mouth
of the staple remover can underneath the
staple depress it pull it out and then
dispose on the gauls
and repeat we're paying attention to our
wound making sure it's not opening up
stay nice and close and it is here's our
last one and we moved a total of seven
staples so we'll document that now we're
gonna clean the area with a new swab on
where we remove the staples and then
we'll let it dry and apply new
steri-strips now the area's dried so
we're going to go ahead and apply our
steri-strips just like how we did before
over where each staple was that we
removed just line it up
then we're going to apply our mix one
just like we did the other one and these
serious trips sometimes get stuck on
your gloves so just be aware of that and
we're going to apply our next one again
just lining it up
then we're going to apply our last one
here at the end
so we have our series strips on now
you'll want to assess and think about
you know is this area at risk for being
rubbed up against something like
friction or going to experience a lot of
sweating here on the leg no not really
but I've had patients who have had
incisions in their groin and this area
rubs up against the jeans it can get
sweaty so you can apply a dressing over
that and teach the patient how to change
it regularly and monitor the site until
the steri-strips fall off now the series
strips will fall off all by themselves
within about 10 day so tell the patient
not to remove the strip's now after
you've done that you'll want to dispose
of your staples they're a sharps so they
will go in the sharps box or dispose
however your Hospital requires you to
dispose of these and dolf your gloves
and perform hand hygiene so that wraps
up this video on how to remove surgical
staples thank you so much for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for more videos